indeed you are busy with the world the
affairs
competition with one another
trying to race with one another
trying to
prove something to one another people
put in pictures of the stuff that they
own or shall i say trying to own
or are indebted to
why
because they are too busy in rivalry
i have to prove the other person wrong i
need to see him i'm doing better than
him everyone's racing with one another
until you visit the graves
allah says until you visit the graves
and no
surely you're going to know
and i'll repeat this statement
brothers and sisters a little a very
beautiful brother called
who i had the honor to work with in this
on on with iman channel
a very beautiful brother that i know him
through three things three things i know
i mean very briefly i did a bit of
president presenting with him but i know
him for three
categorical things the first one is
brother and sisters that he would
tell us a bit about his story what i
mean we will sit down we'll talk a neat
he will tell me a story about you know
he's to chase you know
music and all this kind of stuff and he
was working with certain people in the
industry
and how allah guided him
and he used to cry every time he used to
tell me story he used to cry the guy he
spoke from his heart
he used to always get in tears and cry
the second thing i remember him is how
soft he was spoken like i have never
ever
i think ever come across anybody
so innocent and sweet in his speech like
so soft that when you look at him you
will see this person i don't think he's
the type to back bite i don't think it's
the time to talk about others his
demeanor and the words that came out his
mouth is something where you would like
nah this guy and backbiting are
contradictions like it wouldn't i'm not
saying people can fall into it but it's
not something that you would expect for
he was very soft-spoken very gentle
always assuming the best in people
a beautiful man
the third thing which i loved about
what
and it amazed me when he would talk
about his past another thing that he
would always talk about is his mother
continuously continuously he will talk
about his mom how he take cares of his
mom he lives in london but has to travel
all the way to birmingham because she's
not well she's got arthritis and a few
other illnesses that he would go and
cater for her two to three times a week
and i can remember at one point i was
looking for a phone or i was sending my
phone i can't remember on instagram and
he was saying
i'm thinking of buying my mama phone
he was at the service of his mother this
guy was at the service of his mother
he saw a man a yemeni man having his mom
on his shoulders
going around the kaabah
and the man after he finished the tower
for his mom he came to omar and said
omar
have i paid my mom back
for what she has done for me
um i looked at him and said
you have not paid back your mother
for one off she said when she's giving
birth to you one off
there are muslims who abuse their mother
who swear out their mother i've seen
with my own eyes and heard of my own
ears
this video in a nutshell just wrapped up
brother and sisters
is
in his memory
because i can vouch and i will stand in
front of allah to what kind of man this
man was he even planned to go umrah or
hajj if i'm not mistaken
he changed his way alhamdulillah and he
used to pray qiyan he used to pray
tarawi with the brothers when his iman
channel when i was down finished
presenting i would come down he would
sleep there on the couch
and pray
this is what he's known for and we will
testify to allah on your makayama that
we saw our brother praying looking after
his mom and regretting his past which is
a form of repentance anyways
may allah give you the highest ranks of
jannah or
if you do not see us in paradise ask
about us you was a beautiful soul
you was an amazing son and when i say
this i get i'm getting shivers
you will be missed aki may allah bless
you may allah grant you the highest
ranks of jannah may allah give your
family patience
you was a beautiful soul may allah
subhanahu wa accept you we know you
through that and we will remember you
through that inshallah brothers and
sisters we're all going to die
what are you going to be remembered for
your friends coming and pouring alcohol
down your grave huh
is this what you want to be remembered
for
that you was a gangster yeah you was a
foster you was like what was you huh
that used to backpipe each other
may allah give us a good ending may
allah accept it from us may allah allow
us to serve his religion with our wealth
with our health
with everything that we have inshallah
there is a sadakajare project of two
wells with all my welfare trust the link
will be there please give whatever you
can may allah subhanahu wa tell them
bless you guys keep us firm this life is
not worth our brother sisters do not be
busy showing you're proving yourself to
other people be busy and occupy proving
yourself to allah because at the end
every single one of these people that
you're trying to prove to are all going
to leave you and you know what they're
going to be against you the only one
that's going to be there for is allah
islam
sorry guys um because the video was
quite emotional i forgot to mention he
actually passed away and he went to do
wudu and when he went to do wudo the
moment he stepped out with the
intentions to pray he collapsed and died
i'm so sorry i forgot to mention this
but this is how he died a beautiful
death um
why don't you join us for the biggest
game show on tv this ramadan the quest
for umrah every sunday is in ramadan
from 6 p.m where you have the
opportunity to win a trip to umrah
the quest for umrah
sundays at 6 pm